Musik
Hallo! Jetzt macht sie langsam, gewöhnt euch ans Licht, dreht euch noch mal um, guckt nur die Decke, guckt mal auf die Uhr, alles entspannt heute. Die Decke über den Kopf ziehen, das Büro kann heute warten, ihr bleibt heute mal ganz kuschelig zu Hause. Wenn ein Füsslein rausgerutscht ist, dann schön noch mal einpacken, schön noch mal einpacken und die Decke so um den Fuss herumlegen, damit es so wie so schlafsackartig eingemummelt ist. Eingemummelt auch ein tolles Wort. Vielen Dank an Erik, der uns mit diesem fantastischen frivolen Klängen heute in den Tag begleitet, denn wir sagen Hallo und guten Morgen, streckt euch nochmal die Podcast-Ufo, guten Morgen Ausgabe, es ist sehr, sehr früh. Ich hasse es, wenn Podcasters machen, ohne Scheiß, weil man hört es nie dann, wenn die aufzeichnen. Natürlich nicht. Die Podcast-Haus meinen immer, sie müssten ihr Feeling gerade, mir toll übertragen. Es kommt immer zur Primetime-Haus. Und heute irgendwo abends beim Feiern hören die jetzt so eine, oh, leg dich nochmal hin-Folge. Niemand Bock drauf. Also das ist das. Schön vom Dancefloor zurückgezogen auf die Toilette, um nochmal sich schön die Stöpsel ins Ohr zu ballern, einfach um zu sagen, wer kein Ja, aber ich brauche eine kurze Pause. Wer kein Ja, aber mit kurzen Intervallphasen. Und diese Intervallphasen sind, oh, guten Morgen, oh, Alter hat die Fresse, scheiß Podcast-Haus. Skips, skips, skips, skips. Podcast-Haus ist eigentlich in ihrer eigenen Scheißwelt. Erstens will dem niemand zuhören, die meinen immer alle, die wollen dem zuhören, niemand will dem zuhören. Zweitens meinen sie immer, die möglichst die Tagestell zu übertragen. Ich glaube, es hören uns auch viele auf doppelter Geschwindigkeit, wo dann dieses sehr gemütliche, dann sehr gehetzt rüberkommt und überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Was sagst du eigentlich, du als Netflix-Creator? Ja. Was sagst du eigentlich zu der vielleicht geplanten Funktion auf Netflix, Serien mit 1,5-facher Geschwindigkeit anschauen zu können? Habe ich viel drüber gel, auch, dass es eigentlich nur eine Vorspulfunktion sein soll. Habe ich auch gelesen wiederum. Das ist nicht das fixierte Vorspulen aller Zeiten. Also ihr könnt Vorspulen jetzt mit 30 Frames pro Sekunde. War das nicht so wie damals bei DVDs? Konntest du auch einmal draufklicken, dann war 1,5, einmal dann war 4, so keine Ahnung. Jetzt habe ich auch gelesen, war aber auch ein weirdes Zurückrudern von Netflix, die meinten, nee, das war nur so, um nach vorne zu gucken, das war gar nicht gemeint, um schneller zu gucken. Ja, ich finde es Quatsch, ich finde es Quatsch, es sollte den, also wenn das Seriencreator oder Filmcreator halt so wollen, dass man das, ihr Medium, ihr Film so gucken kann, dann sollen sie es doch bitte zulassen, auf der anderen Seite finde ich es blöd, das als Werkseinstellung es ermöglichen. Ich finde, man sollte den Film so gucken, wie er von den Künstlern intendiert ist. Aber was wäre für dich eher ein Kompliment, wenn jemand sagt, ich habe deine komplette Serie auf eineinhalbfach geschaut oder auf 0,5?
Ja, 0,5. Das finde ich okay. Ich finde da unten ist okay.
Moritz, wir müssen endlich drogen. Ja, dann aber schnell jetzt. Ich muss noch mal im Computer nachschauen. Es ist schwierig, aber gut, wer weiß, ob es kommt. Ich glaube, es gibt viele, die unseren Podcast schon mit 1,5-Fahrer Geschwindigkeit hören, die mit großer Geschwindigkeit, die so in der ganzen Zeit so klingt, die einfach sich das ganze Rennen ballert und sagt, okay, ich bin 200 Folgen hinterher, ich muss mich ein bisschen beschleunigen. Ja, sonst komme ich nicht hinterher, aber auf der Seite rede ich das und so schnell, das macht gar keinen Sinn, uns in doppelter Geschwindigkeit zu hören, da hast du ja gar nichts mehr, also so schnell kann man man auch nicht mal Informationen aufnehmen, muss man auch mal sagen. Ich bin ja noch weiter beim Französischlernen dabei und ich struggle momentan so ein bisschen, weil die Motivation lässt nach, bin ich sehr ehrlich und ich habe jetzt schon alle Karambolage angeschaut, diese kleinen Arte-Kurzfilme, die sind nett, kann man sich angucken und ich habe jetzt auch überlegt, weil auf YouTube kann man ja auch die Abspielgeschwindigkeit ändern und dann dachte ich mir, ich mache so französischen Videos halt so, weil du willst ja die krassen Sachen angucken, du willst ja nicht immer bei Kinderbüchern bleiben, du willst die Talkshows mit Timothy Chalamet anschauen, du willst irgendwie das Interview mit Vincent Cassel anschauen, so wo du denkst, okay krass, da kann ich jetzt mal Dinge angucken, die ich sonst nicht hätte angucken können. Du willst eine neue Welt erschließen und damit auch eine neue Kultur. Gerard de Padieux-Doku. Das dauert. So, das dauert. Überdenk mal, wie lange es bei dir auch mit Englisch gedauert hat, also bei jedem. Ja, ja, und dann dachte ich mir, okay, dann schaue ich halt auf halber Geschwindigkeit, weil dann ist es langsam, dann habe ich mehr Chance zu verstehen. Wenn du in Frankreich Urlaub machst, singst du ein kompletter Retard. Bonjour, je, und vor allem, ich dachte mir, okay, schau dir das an, aber ich war am Ende so gelangweilt, dass ich fast eingeschlafen bin, weil es hat so eine beruhigende, weil Französische sind eine sehr aggressive Sprache in normaler Geschwindigkeit, aber in halber Geschwindigkeit klingt es dann so und es ist so einfach so ein Wabern und du bist wie in so einem riesengroßen Camembert, singst du so langsam ein. Hat da jemand Wahlgesang abgespeedet und ist das nicht einfach französisch?
Ja, Paul, Paul, Paul, Paul, Paul, Paul, Paul, Paul. Und Paul wurde leider getötet von Wahlfängern aus Thailand. Aber deswegen ruft der Wahl heute noch, deswegen mussten die Forscher das wieder begraben, diese Erkenntnis. Weil es zu traurig ist. Es ist zu traurig, ja. Aber ich glaube, wenn man Wahlgesang abspielt, ist es einfach von so. YouTube checkt ja auch nicht, dass man welche Videos man in halber Geschwindigkeit guckt dann und macht dann einfach, sagt dann, okay, Florentin will jetzt alle Videos auf halber Geschwindigkeit haben und danach guckst du dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ein Musikvideo und es ist auch halber Geschwindigkeit. Also ich glaube, ich bin mittlerweile so desensibilisiert für irgendwas, ich kriege fast nichts mehr mit. Also ich kriege das teilweise gar nicht mehr mit, wenn Videos sind, eineinhalbfache Geschwindigkeit, ich bin immer so ein bisschen weird geschnitten, aber dann irgendwann nach 20 Minuten merke ich, fuck, das ist ja eineinhalbfache Geschwindigkeit. Manchmal habe ich auch noch mal in Spotify nebenbei laufen und denke mir so, die Musik passt gerade gar nicht in der Doku. Ach nee, das ist mein Telefon. Und das merke ich auch erst so viel zu spät. Ich glaube, ich habe einen grossen Teil meines Medienkonsums, das ist einfach total chaotisch. Du schaust eine klassische Hitler-Doku und irgendwie im Hintergrund Bruno Mars die ganze Zeit einfach... Take on me die ganze Zeit., merkwürdige Musikwahl, aber okay. Und der erste Putsch und du denkst dir, okay, merkwürdig. Aber ich habe, während du eine Sprache gelernt hast, deinen Tipp befolgt und eine App heruntergeladen, die da heisst Human Resource Machine. Eine ganz, ganz tolle App, eine tolle Rätsel-App, wo es, du hast es erklärt, was einem so ein bisschen Programmieren näher bringt, also so Automatismen zu schreiben und so und ich habe da unfassbar viel Spaß dran. Jetzt bei Level 29 ist mir dann aber auch zu aufwendig. Da muss man sich hinsetzen und aktiv nachdenken und vielleicht auch mal was aufschreiben oder oder man muss zumindest darüber sinnieren ein bisschen, bis man dann die ersten Bausteine zieht. Aber bis dahin ging es relativ smooth und war ich auch teilweise stolz drauf, weil man hat das Gefühl, man kriegt Lösungsansätze hin. Und ich habe immer zu viele Schritte, ich habe immer viel zu viele Schritte. Ich habe, glaube ich, immer so Lösungsansätze, wie damals in der Mathe eigentlich auch.
Immer Lösungsstimmte dann auf eine Art, aber weirder Weg dahin. Der Weg dahin ist komplett offroad. Man hält sich auch so ganz lange auf mit 2x ist gleich 2,5. Ja. 3x wäre dann mehr, 3,3. Man hat auch das viele Zwischenlösungen. Ich biete mal was an. Ihr wollt nicht wissen, was 3x sind, aber hier ist das ein 3x? Ich weiß noch, dass tatsächlich das, was mich in Mathe am meisten behindert hat, war Seitenumblättern. Weil ich habe immer irgendwie das Ergebnis, dann so ein Buch, keine Ahnung, irgendwie irgendwas. Sagen wir jetzt mal halt Zahlen, ja, halt verschiedene Zahlen. Sag mal eine Zahl. Ja, sag mal halt ein Sechstel, so.
Nee, sag mal eine Zahl.
Ja.
Nicht als Bruch.
Ja, dann sagen wir halt ne neun, ja, okay, so, ein Neuntel, so, nee, sagen wir mal ein Neuntel, so, und dann hatte ich auf einer Seite ewig rumgerechnet, um zu einem Neuntel zu kommen, und dann blätter ich um und schreibe ab dann sieben Neuntel. Weil ich meine eigene fucking Eins nicht mehr lesen kann. Weil ich das übertrage... Neue Seite, neues Glück. Bei mir war es so, der ganze Rechenweg ist weg. Also wenn ich ihn nicht mehr vor mir sehe, direkt ist der ganze Weg dahin, ich kann noch neu anfangen einfach. Was bei mir in Mathe-Schulaufgaben am meisten stand, war der Lehrer, der geschrieben hat, auf der letzten Seite war das noch eine Eins. Trauriger Smiley. Und ab jetzt ist alles falsch, weil ich es irgendwie selber nicht gelesen habe. Aber dann haben doch Lehrer auch die Möglichkeit. Folgefehler, ist ein Folgefehler, ist doch klar. Ist ein Folgefehler, ist ein klassischer FF. Ist ein FF, ist doch klar. War das dritte Reichlich auch immer ein Folgefehler? Ja, ist eine interessante, oh, da könnte ich jetzt ausholen, aber. Willst du nicht ausholen? Hol doch mal aus. Hol mal schön mit Schmackes aus. Wir machen mal hier wie so eine typische Morning-Sendung, die haben wir diese, die erst Take on Me von Aha spielen und danach Zeitzeichen Holocaust und so. Aber Zeitzeichen ist immer schön, dass man mal kurz ausholt. Da sitzt ein Mark Bensko und man muss dann so, und sie haben ein neues Albumbum rausgebracht und dann, also da muss ich das erstmal ausholen. Also, 14, 22, ja, Abkommen, gab es natürlich verschiedene Fehlenderpräderation und einfach noch mal die komplette Menschheitsgeschichte, weil die Leute schütten sich in Orangensaft ein und reden mit ihren Kindern und ist egal, was man sagt. Blättern die Zeitungen, diese schöne, diese riesen Blätterzeitung. Tim Bensko, vielen Dank, das neue Album ist ab morgen erhältlich.
Jetzt Bruno Mars mit Lazy Song.
Lazy Song?
Der Lazy Song.
Ich kann noch ein bisschen tanzen.
Tim, wir sind im Radio.
Soll ich tanzen?
Ja, für die Webcam, aber du brauchst ganz langsam tanzen, wir machen, jedes, jede fünf Minuten machen wir ein Bild für die Webcam.
Gut, danke. Was ist das mit Seitenumblättern, wo wolltest du gerade irgendwas? Das ist ein schönes Gefühl, diese riesige Seitenumblättern. Hat man selten mehr, ne? Die Zeitungen, ja, ganz klein, die werden immer kleiner. Auch so Magazine werden immer kleiner, habe ich letztens gesehen, die Cosmopolitan in so einer Pocket-Version. Ja, iPad. Kleine Version, so klein, so für die Handtasche oder so. Finde ich richtig gut. Aber, nee, wenn man vermisst, dass dieses große, die Zeit. Ja, ja, ja. Man liest auch die Zeit primär wegen des Umblättergefühls. Ja. Und das Gefühl zu haben, man kauft sich, ist ja dieses, hat ja jeder Mensch, dieses Anfassen wollen, das haben ja gerade wir, die damit nicht mehr aufwachsen so richtig, hat man ja ganz doll manchmal. Und so eine Zeitung zu kaufen, ich hatte neulich so am Wochenende wirkliches Bedürfnis, mich morgens in einen Kaffee zu setzen. Orangensaft, Kaffee, Zeitung und ein Croissant. Ja und dann so ein gekochtes Ei. Gekochtes Ei, tipp, tipp, tipp, tipp und brrrrsch. Kleines bisschen Salz. Und dann was zu weich gekocht und brrrrsch über die Zeit. Ist das Schale im Mund? Über die Zeit und dann springt man auf, da bestellt man den orangischen Saft auf die Nachbarin. Aber so ein Mohagen wünscht man sich immer wieder. Zeitungslesen ist eine Kunst, eine Fähigkeit. Das ist eine Naht an Origami. Wer das hinkriegt, das mit einem und dann auch so zu knicken und zu falten, das das hinkriegt, das können nicht alle. Und vor allem eine Zeitung wieder so zurückzufalten in die Ursprungsvariante, wo man ja sagen müsste, es ist ja nicht so schwierig eigentlich, weil alle Seiten geben ja vor, in welche Richtung man das faltet. Aber die knicken nicht immer an der Pfalz. Die knicken nicht immer an der Pfalz. Die knicken nicht immer an der Pfalz. Und so heißt die Folge auch deswegen heute. Die knicken nicht immer an der Pfalz. Die knicken nicht immer an der Pfalz. Die knicken nicht immer an der Pfalz. Oh, wie hast du gestern den Karneval gefeiert eigentlich, gestern, 11.11.? Äh, habe gar nicht gefeiert. Wie jedes Jahr vergessen, dass dieser Tag existiert. Wir kommen morgen raus, morgens raus und man ist kurz in dieser, in dieser, wir müssen auch mal darüber sprechen, es gibt so Phasen am Tag, also wenn man morgens aufwacht, man ist ja noch nicht bei sich, man guckt so auf die Welt herab und man sieht dann immer so eine ganz seltsame Welt und dann war direkt vor meiner Tür mit Schmetterling neben dem Top Gun Menschen und du weißt noch nicht, was los ist. Du brauchst so eine Stunde, bis du sagst, ah, Elter, Elter. Du hast so das Gefühl, du bist eine Stunde zu spät in den Film reingegangen und willst nicht nachfragen und musst jetzt selber so ein bisschen. Genau. Okay, der Marienkäfer ist die haben ihren der marienkäfer ist schwul und mit dem top gun-typen zusammen und die schmetterlingsfrau kotzt in meiner einfahrt jetzt diskutiert gerade joker mit arthur wader die haben was sagt er lall man versteht auch alle ganz schlecht in diesem versuch das lauter zu machen ja und dann irgendwann aha War Elfter, Elfter. Jetzt gibt's zwei Napoleons, das ist diese Zeitreise.
Ah, Klonen, Klonen oder Zeitreise. Oder man weiß nicht genau. Bei mir war es auch so, ich habe es auch erst nicht gecheckt, ich steige aus dem Zug aus und sehe erst mal schön fünf mit fünf Ziger Damen alle Marienkäfer. Alle Marienkäfer. Alle Marienkäfer und ich dachte mir, oh schön. Gleiche Punktanzahl, keine Punktanzahl. Ich habe nicht nachgezählt, aber ich würde sagen, die Älteste hatte die meisten Punkte. Ja. Und dann dachte ich mir erst so, oh, Junggesellenabschied. Nervig. Und dann kommt der nächste Junggesellenabschied. Und irgendwann hat das... Und dann geht es weiter und ich hatte irgendwie nur so Pärchenkostüme und dann waren so zwei Jungs, die so Bierfässer waren. Da dachte ich mir, könnte auch noch ein Junggesellenabschied werden. Und dann die sechs... Man will ja auch an seiner Theorie festhalten. Ja, klar. Und dann schaust du so über die Domplatte und du siehst ein Meer an Jokern und denkst dir, hmm, oder vielleicht doch... Demo. Demo, ja, der Film war ganz okay, der Film war ganz okay und du so, ich habe keine Meinung, ich habe keine Meinung, ist das okay? Wobei man muss sagen, dass ich habe keine Meinung, die kontroverseste Meinung zum Joker-Film wäre, den man entweder mega findet oder heutzutage ist glaube ich, ich habe keine Meinung, ein legitimer Grund auf die Straße zu gehen. Ja, ja, ich glaube, es gibt keine Daumen nach links Version, es gibt eine nach oben unten Variante Knopf. Nicht Herzchen und nicht Daumen runter, nicht Herzchen und nicht Daumen runter. Er ist keine Eins, er ist keine Zehn, er ist eher so eine Vier. Vor allem, du feindest dich mit allen an. Ja. So beide, beide Lager können sich zusammenschliessen, um dich zusammenzuschlagen. Du wirst komplett aufgerieben. Ja, Polizeischutz und so. Ja, das ist aber nicht eine kontroverse Meinung. Hast du ihn gesehen, Joker-Film? Ja, ja.
Aber vor allem interessant die Momente, wo dann auch der Heath Ledger-Joker auf den Joaquin-Phoenix-Joker treffen an Karneval. Und dann ist so ein Stardown, so ein, wer ist der bessere Joker? Und du denkst dir, da liegt eine riesige Diskussion in der Luft, wären die beide nicht rotzevoll, würde jetzt vielleicht hier eine interessante popkulturelle Analyse stattfinden. Dann kommt der Jared Leto Joker.
Und der ist sich selber bewusst, dass er nicht der beste Joker ist.
Und geht davon dann. Obwohl ich das fast ein bisschen fies finde. Jared Leto ist wahrscheinlich multimillionär Rockstar und Schauspieler, aber ich finde es trotzdem ein bisschen gemein, dass der gemobbt wird dafür, dass der Joker. Gemobbt wird? Ja, da gibt es dann diese Memes so, ah, wer ist der beste Joker und dann, ah, du gehörst nicht dazu und so, das muss nicht sein. Wirklich gibt es diese Memes? Der hat auch Gefühle, ja, alle machen den Jared Leto Joker fertig. Ich habe den Film nicht gesehen, ich kann dazu nichts sagen, aber... Ist schon scheiße. Ja, kann schon sein, aber, Alter, ist auch, man muss doch... Nur weil Leute reich und berühmt sind, heißt es nicht, dass man sie fertig machen kann. Nicht, sorry, dann möchte ich es gerne zurücknehmen. Sorry, Jared. Nimm das bitte gerne zurück. Deswegen, verkleidet euch als Bärchen, da tut ihr niemandem weh. Gut, Ironik-Lobby vielleicht, aber ansonsten merkt. Gestern waren ganz viele Jungs als Ahoy-Brause verkleidet und Brokkoli. Das waren so die beiden Tendenzen, Trends, die ich letzten Tag erkennen konnte. Das sind so semi-ironische Kostüme. Semi-ironisch, die dann aber wieder durchs Tragen natürlich jegliche Ironie verlieren. Ahoi-Brause, aber alle unterschiedlich. Der eine war Orange, der andere war Waldmeister. Das finde ich aber super clever, wenn dann für Frauen, die dann mit den Jungs das anfangen an dem Tag und so, und dann können sie direkt sagen, ja, der ist so süß da hinten, der Orange, nee, Waldmeister. Ja, genau. Das ist halt gut, um zu differenzieren. Und vor allem, du kannst sie direkt im Handy abspeichern als Waldmeister. Waldmeister. Du weißt, ah, der Waldmeister von gestern. Der Waldmeister war süss. Nee, ich mag Orange lieber. Ja, brillant, oder? Weil das ist ja einfach eine laufende Werbeanzeige. Ich meine, gut, klar ist es jetzt für Ahoi, wenn der komplett sich eingekotzt in der Ecke liegt, irgendwie auf der Domplatte. Nicht die beste Werbung der Welt, aber bis dahin. Also Schaum vorm Mund.
Bei Ahoi-Brause.
Zu dem Punkt, wo man noch aufnahmefähig ist,
ist es eine gute Werbung auf jeden Fall. Oh, das ist das, oh.
Epileptiker sollten das nicht machen.
Mit Ahoi-Brause.
Stell dir mal vor, du liest mit Schaum vorm Mund,
irgendwann auf der Domplatte,
hast aber ein Ahoi-Brause-Kostüm.
Es ist so wirrend.
Es sieht so aus, als ob du jemand,
der spielt ja an einer Überdosis Ahoi-Brause,
stimmst. Es sieht nicht aus, als ob du dich ernsthaft
Vielen Dank. auf der Domplatte, hast aber ein Ahoi-Brause-Kostüm. Es sieht so aus, als ob du jemanden, der spielt ja eine Überdosis Ahoi-Brause, stellst. Es sieht nicht aus, als ob du wirklich ernsthaft ein Problem hast. Oder auch so diese ganzen Zombie-Kostüme mit den ganzen Wunden und dem Blut, wenn die sich ernsthaft verletzen. Der Notarzt denkt sich, willst du mich verarschen, was geschieht ihr? Es ist gefährlich. Welche Wunde ist echt, welche ist geschminkt? Die ist ja heutzutage auch so gut geschminkt. Ja, dann näht er da was zusammen, das war eigentlich gar nicht zusammen, ne. Gummi näht er da zusammen, wird wieder reanimiert und sagt, nein, ich bin kein Geist, das ist nur ein Kostüm. Oder so ein Skelett, wo er sagt, der ist tot. Schrecklich. Wird für tot erklärt dann auch schnell, dann bist du ja noch im Leben, weil du hast ja nur, dann kannst du die Maske abziehen. Es ist extrem verwirrend. Es ist gefährlich, ich bin auch froh, dass wir vorbei sind. Es ist gut, dass es nur einen Tag dauert, deswegen kann man es auch tolerieren. Ich bunker mich da ein, ich versuche die Stadt zu verlassen. Wobei ich wollte ja jetzt aktiv teilnehmen, ging jetzt nicht wegen Arbeit, aber tatsächlich jetzt die kommende fünfte Jahreszeit, die mache ich glaube ich einmal mal mit. Einfach mal mal gucken. Es hat ein paar Jahre gedauert jetzt, um überhaupt in den Genuss zu kommen, es vielleicht mal in Erwägung zu ziehen. Ich glaube, ich mache das mal. Du willst vom Lifestyle-Stefan direkt zum Paul-Stefan wieder zurück. Letztes Jahr wollte ich ja Han Solo, als Han Solo gehen, ging dann nicht wegen Krankheit. Da hat mich die Krankheit dann niedergerafft. Was vielleicht das beste Anzeichen ist, nicht als Han Solo zu gehen. So ein hartgesottener Schmuggler und dann kann er nicht weil, oh, leicht erkält. Umarme mich nicht, ich bin krank. Tu ihn nicht. Du sollst das Fenster zumachen. Ich meine, diese Klimaanlagen auch. Ja. Ein großes Problem. Ich war aber wirklich fliegen, jetzt am Wochenende. Ja? Ich war zum ersten Mal mit meinem Flugkollegen, meinem Chef, unterwegs in seiner kleinen Maschine und es war wirklich fantastisch. Es hat so viel Spaß gemacht und ich habe ja schon vor ein paar Wochen mal erzählt, dass ich vielleicht eine Erwägung ziehe, nächstes Jahr langsam einen Flugschein anzufangen und ich glaube nicht, dass ich das mache. Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Wir waren auch da an der Flugschule, sind da abgehoben und sind knapp drei Stunden rumgeflogen und das war schon cool.
Und einfach nur wirre durch die Gegend geflogen, oder was? Oder du machst das in der Sightseeing-Tour dann so ein bisschen? Ne, wir haben Sightseeing-Tour gemacht, eine Freundin war auch dabei und wir sind über unsere jeweiligen Häuser in der Heimat geflogen, weil wir beide aus NRW kommen und sind da rüber geflogen, haben unsere Eltern in den Garten gerufen und winken lassen. Dann haben wir ein paar Flybys gemacht an Flughäfen, also am Tower vorbei und gewunken, die Sachen, die man so halt so macht. Also so Lob, Lob, Lob. Darf man das? Ja, man muss halt vorher mit den Funken. Du bist ja generell die ganze Zeit am Funken. Du hast auch, also das Weirdeste ist, du hast ja eh leider Kopfhörer auf, man unterhält sich ja nur über Mikrofonen am Kopfhörer. Also alle klingen erst mal zehn, zehn Grad cooler, weil alle diese geile K-Stimme haben, die ja so geil verzerrt wird und auch, ich glaube, runtergepitcht wird auch und da ist ein Voice-Act dahinter, der nochmal viel drüber spricht. Es ist viel cooler. Und dann haben alle noch Musik drauf, weil es gibt ein ganz normales Aux-Kabel, wie in einem Auto auch, dass du kannst Musik drauf machen, jeder hat Musik auf seinen Kopfhörern und kann nicht drüber sprechen ist total cool, es klingt wie ein Musikvideo. Wie oft habt ihr Dänischer Zone gehört? Die ganze Zeit Dänischer Zone, zu oft mein Geschmack. Und dann wird ab und zu kommt da noch Funk rein. Und das ist ganz seltsam, weil ich hab dann ab und zu, ich hab dann tatsächlich den Ocean's Eleven Soundtrack angemacht und da sind manchmal halt Sprüche drauf. Da hört man manchmal noch Brad Pitt sprechen. Und man hört auch manchmal einen Anruf. Das ist 9-on-1, dem Emergency. Hört man theoretisch auch, das ist ein bisschen problematisch, weil auf die Musik auch noch die ganze Zeit die Funksprüche kommen von diversen Towern und Flugsicherungen usw. Hatte dann aber unser Kollege auf dem Schirm, der hat den ganzen Tag mit dem gesprochen.
Super cool, das hat wirklich sehr viel Spaß gemacht und die waren auch alle sehr entspannt.
Also die haben wir alles machen lassen, also Tiefflüge, Flybys an Flughäfen, waren am Köln-Bonner Flughafen, Dortmunder Flughafen waren wir und das war fantastisch.
Ich finde, das so abgefahren, weil da so diese Welten, diese super professionelle Flughafenwelt, irgendwie tausende von Passagieren, aber am Ende sagen die auch einfach, ja, fliegen ist halt geil. Ja klar, komm, fliegen vorbei, scheiß auf, ja, setzt euch ins Cockpit. Wir haben so schüchtern gefragt, wir würden gerne vom Dom zum, Dom ist halt immer so, ja, wir wollen einfach mal rumfliegen, vomom Dom zum Flughafen rum. Ja, komm. Die hat sogar einen Namen, diese Tourismusroute. Habe ich nicht vergessen, wie die heisst. Sierra oder sowas. Aber man kann einmal, ich bin einmal um den Dom, sehr nahe um den Dom herum geflogen. War kein Ding, kann man einfach machen. Um den Dom rum, zack, Richtung Flughafen, dann da fast gelandet und dann Left Off. Das war nicht schön. Das war nicht schön. Ich muss die Checklist vorlesen am Anfang, habe vielleicht was vergessen, um ehrlich zu sein, 100 pro was vergessen, weil sehr viele Checkpunkte sind, aber das war wirklich cool. Ich glaube, ich mache das. Und dann fliegen wir mal hin. Dann können wir auch mal zu unseren Live-Auftritten fliegen. Oh, das ist nicht schlecht, dann landen wir so direkt auf der Bühne, aber du brauchst ja dann auch, sag ich mal, auch ein Flugzeug. Ja. Also Flugscheine, eine reichte nicht. Oder gibt es da so plane to go? Ja, es gibt plane to go. Es gibt plane to go. An jedem Flugraum kann man sich eigentlich auch ein Flugzeug leihen. Ist halt wahnsinnig teuer. Das ist ein generell Problem, weil es ist ein Hobby, dass alles wahnsinnig teuer ist. Aber es gibt einen Piloten-Shortage. Das heißt, es wird aktiv gesucht, weil es gibt wenige Leute, die das noch lernen. Es wachsen nicht so viele Piloten nach. Und deswegen kann man sich ja auch ein paar Cents nebenbei verdienen, so Uber-mäßig, weißt du, da muss immer Leute rumfliegen. Ernsthaft? Ja. Es gibt Leute, die hingeflogen werden wollen? Ja, so Privatjets und so. Ja gut, aber ein Jet ist ja nochmal was anderes, das war ja irgendwie so eine Rödelmaschine,, damit er geflogen sei. Nö, das ist schon eine Jahr als Rödelmaschine. Definiere Rödelmaschine. Naja, wo es noch ordentlich klappert im Parkbild. Ja, doch. Da kann man jetzt auch nicht so viel gegen sein. Wo es noch links und rechts offen ist, wo man noch so einen Fuß raushängen kann. Nee, tatsächlich, aber kann man damit auch schon ordentlich Leute transportieren und ein bisschen grösser kann, sondern da gibt es dann schon Maschinen, die ähnlich motorisiert sind, die hinten so eine Art Konferenzraum schon drin haben, wo du dann auch am Tisch und gegenüber sitzen kannst und so weiter. Geht schon. Da gibt es einen Shortage. Das ist eine ganz neue Welt. Ich wäre ja auch dann bereit, wenn es mal Waldbrände gibt, dann in Deutschland auch mal Wasser. Schön mit so einer Sprite-Flasche einfach aus dem Fenster. Ja, ich halte die Flasche aus dem Fenster. Sie ist vorbei, kein Problem, machst du. Oder nein, Sprite brennt ja noch doller. Ah, stimmt. Vergessen. Manchmal vergisst das manchmal. Aber wäre nicht zum Einstieg so Segelflug oder sowas? Ja, zu langweilig. War ein großes Thema bei uns an der Schule, wir haben eine große Segelflugschule. Ja, ich habe ja ein Praktikum gemacht im Deutschen Museum und habe mich da in der Segelflugabteilung verdingt. Und da habe ich mich sechs Wochen intensiv mit Segelflug beschäftigt, aber war dann trotzdem keinen Bock drauf. Hätte auch eine Woche gereicht, dann machen wir uns nichts vor. Hätte auch eine Stunde gereicht. Was willst du dir sechs Wochen mit Segelflugen beschäftigen? Es ist doch, du hebst ab und fliegst und dann irgendwann kommst du runter. Ja, aber du musst ja gucken, dass du dann in der Luft bleibst. Dann musst du so die verschiedenen thermodynamischen Effekte nutzen, irgendwie oben zu bleiben. Aber im Endeffekt runterkommen sie immer. Runterkommen sie immer, das ist nicht das Problem. Vor ein paar Wochen ist ein Fluglehrer abgeschossen mit seinem Schüler. Oh ja, stimmt. Aber das war ja so ein krasser, das war ja so ein Militärjet. Nee, hier an der Flugschule, wo ich dann auch anfangen würde. Da tatsächlich ist vor ein paar Monaten Fluglehrer gestorben mit seinem Schüler. Einfach weil, man weiß nicht genau warum. Das ist ein bisschen problematisch. Das Ding ist aber auch, man hört ja, also es hat so einen gefährlichen Anschein, macht es immer, weil ja über jeden Unfall berichtet wird. Das ist ja anders als beim Motorrad oder beim Auto, wird ja beim Flugzeug exklusiv über jeden Unfall, den es gibt, berichtet. Es ist ja immer eine Newsmeldung, wenn ein Flugzeug abstürzt.
Und deswegen glaube ich, hat das so ein verruchter Alles klappert, sehr unsicher.
So ein Anstrich, aber jetzt ist ja eigentlich Quatsch. Oder nicht? Sag doch mal was! Naja, ich weiß es nicht. Es ist immer so, es ist schon was, eher gut wahrscheinlich, aber auf der einen Seite ist es ja so selten, dass man sich immer denkt, was ist da passiert? So, wenn jemand einen Autounfall, wenn du sagst, meine Eltern sind im Autounfall gestorben, dann nimmt das jeder hin mit, ja, der wird halt irgendwie sich einen Cheeseburger reingedrückt haben, irgendwie der wird halt aus Versehen dann, keine Ahnung, irgendwie noch so ein bisschen Sojasauce über seinen Sushi getan haben am Steuer und dann ist ihm so ein bisschen Sojasauce ins Gesicht gespritzt und dann konnte er nicht sehen und dann einen Unfall gebaut. Völlig klar. So war jeder Scheisse baut beim Autofahren, wohingegen beim Flugzeug abgestürzt denkt man sich, wie kann er das machen? Was ist da passiert? Niemand hat ahnen, wie ein Flieger fliegt, aber alle wissen, wie kann das denn sein? Also da muss man doch aufpassen. Man weiss doch, dass es gefährlich ist. Also du siehst doch, ich bin hundert Meter über dem Boden. Da macht man doch keinen Film. Da macht man doch jetzt da oben keinen Film. Man weiss doch, dass es gefährlich ist. Es ist nicht eher ein, ja ist doch klar, dass es passiert ist. Man wartet doch beim Fliegen eher immer drauf, bei diesem ongoing Kampf gegen die Gravitation. Ja. Wartet man doch eher darauf, dass es schief geht. Ist nicht jeder Flug, der nicht schief geht, ein Wunder für die Leute? Aber auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir keine Ahnung. Beim Auto, wenn du auf der Autobahn fährst, dann reicht es, dein Lenkrad einmal halb zu drehen und du bist tot. Wenn du dein Lenkrad einmal halb ruckartig drehst, warst es... Ich glaube, halb muss nicht mehr sein. Ja, oder du kurz bewegst, du bist tot, sofort. Weil du fährst in ein anderes Auto rein, du fährst in den Baum rein. In der Luft? Da ist niemand. Das stimmt nicht. Du bist alleine. Die Chance, ein anderes Flugzeug zu treffen ist gleich null. Du fährst nach oben, ist dann links, oh, ich habe jetzt Drifter ab, oh, oh, ich kann wieder hochziehen. Das Ding ist, man kann auch einfach zwischendurch einfach mal das schlagartig nach links verziehen, das Lenkrad. Das ganze Flugzeug geht dann halt steil nach rechts oder links. Aber es hat wenig Auswirkungen auf den Ort, wo du bist. Du hast halt marginal deine Richtung geändert. Wie du schon sagst, du hast nichts verlassen oder keine Straße verlassen. Das ist ein absurdes Gefühl. Auf der anderen Seite, ich dachte ja immer Radar. Ich dachte immer, das ist doch klar, dass man sofort auf dem Radar angezeigt bekommt, wenn jemand fliegt. Nein, also das ist nicht der Fall. Du musst die ganze Zeit gucken, wo andere Flugzeuge sind, die rasend schnell sind halt auch. Du musst die ganze Zeit das im Blick haben. Das wusste ich auch nicht. Aber du 360 Grad, ob nicht von der Seite dann irgendwie so ein ... Ja, hinten die Flieger sind ja nicht so wild. Von hinten kommen wir seltenen Flieger auf der Höhe, auf der man dann so fliegt, die sind ja auch dann. Aber von vorne oder von rechts und links muss man schon gucken, ob man da entgegenkommt vielleicht. Und es kamen sehr viele Flieger entgegen, wir haben sehr viele Flieger da oben gesehen, da ist ganz schön viel los über NRW, muss man wirklich sagen. Es war irgendwie eines der busiesten Lufträume Europas zumindest mal. Aber das ist trotzdem interessant, weil ich dachte,
auf dem Radar ist man safe,
man sieht dann halt alle Flieger, die gerade
oben rum sind. Nein, das ist ein anderes Fliegen, da muss man ein anderes System
nehmen. Wir sind auf Sicht
geflogen und dann muss man die alle beobachten.
Such dir ein nachhaltiges Hobby,
Fliegen gibt es bald nicht mehr. In ein, zwei
Jahren gibt es keine Flugzeuge mehr und dann
stehst du da mit deinem Flugschein
und denkst dir auch, hätte ich doch mal lieber Schiff
fliegen. Dann wollen alle fliegen, günstig nach Malle fliegen
und dann fliegen sie Ertize,
mein Freund.
Kein Mensch würde Ertize fliegen.
Der ist der einzige, der noch nach Malle fliegt.
Alle anderen, nein, es ist ja,
ich denke da auch an Ultraleichtflieger,
ich denke da an Wasserstoff.
Du bist mit dem Boosted Board
fast tödlich verunglückt, okay, und jetzt willst du RTZ aufmachen. Ja, gut, Boosted Board. Du hast dein Hoverboard in deiner Wohnung zerstört. Ja, ich weiß nicht, wo man lernt das, ich habe ja da keinen sechsmonatigen Kurs gehabt. Was passiert mit deinem Flugzeug, dann bestellst du dir wieder im Internet so ein Billigflugzeug für 1500 Euro. Boosted. Oder sow sich reinsetzt oder sowas in der Richtung und dann ist da der Helm mitgeliefert und dann fliegst du direkt gegen die Wand. Ja, das wird nichts, Stefan. Vielleicht nicht, aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich werde nicht 30. Ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, ja, und ich sage immer Flugzeugabsturz und es ist wie so eine self-fulfilling prophecy jetzt, wo man diesen Willen entwickelt, ein Flugzeug, ein Flugzeug zu machen. Ich glaube, ich werde nicht 30. Flugzeugabsturz, Autounfall, sowas. Autoabsturz, Drogen. Kann passieren, ja. Menschlicher Absturz. Oder was, Bootsunglück, irgendwas peinliches. Angelfehler. Ja. Sowas. Er starb durch einen Angelfehler. Ja, das ist immer tragisch. Ja, es ist sehr tragisch. Genau, aber sowas kann ich mir vorstellen bei mir. Ich glaube, ich werde maximal 28. Okay, dann haben wir noch ein paar schöne Jährchen. Die tausend Folgen machen wir noch voll, oder? Oh, die machen wir noch voll. Gibt es Pläne für die zweitelste Folge eigentlich? Nein, kein Plan von meiner Seite aus. Gut, von meiner Seite auch nicht. Ich finde Jubiläen überschätzt. Es ist zu viel Druck. Ich auch. Man sollte nicht vor allem irgendwann... Ich finde das Silvester überschätzt. Jetzt geht es um die ganzen Anfragen los, so, was machst du Silvester, man muss sich wieder Pläne machen. Es ist so irgendwie auch in meinem Kopf immer zu wichtig, dieses Datum. Jubiläen sind zu wichtig. Alles ist ein bisschen zu wichtig. Diese krassen markanten Daten wie Silvester, wo man immer an sich selber den Anspruch hat, oh, das wird das beste Silvester, ich will das so gut feiern wie noch nie, ich will toll ins neue Jahr kommen und so. Man macht ja immer so viel Druck und dann wird man mit besonderen Leuten abhängen, aber dann sind die wo in Holland und dann muss man mit den B-Leuten abhängen, in der Heimat. Und das ist doch alles Quatsch. Ja, ja. Einfach mal frei machen. Macht mal nichts Silvester. Bleibt mal zu Hause und guckt irgendwie Netflix oder so. Macht einfach einen schönen, ganz normalen Abend. Ja. Diese Pflicht, weinst du jetzt? Diese Pflicht, was zu machen, nervt doch total. Ich versuche es auch ganz locker angehen zu lassen und entspannt. Und vor allem, man kann ja auch mal viel besser darüber nachdenken, was man so im Jahr gemacht hat und was noch kommt. Vorsätze, die direkt wieder verwerfen, die sagen, meine Vorsätze ist es, mir nicht allzu viele Vorsätze zu machen. Man dreht sich da im Kreis seit mehreren Jahren. Die klassischen Tweets halt. Es ist immer wieder, es ist jedes Jahr dasselbe. Und vielleicht müssen wir das auch mal verlegen. Vielleicht brauchen wir mal auch einen anderen Kalender oder sowas. Vielleicht muss sich da wirklich was ändern. Ja, hör doch mal sagen, es ist ja nicht so, dass da die Erde neu sich anfängt, um die Sonne zu drehen, sondern die geht einfach weiter. Dieser harte Cut, der ist ja so menschengemacht, verstehst du? Ich glaube, das ist auch Quatsch, sich da immer in so Jahreszeilen aufzuhängen. Habe ich jetzt auch keine Lösung dafür, aber ich glaube, man muss da weg von. Man muss da weg von. Aber dann 20, dann kann man wieder sagen, 20er Jahre. Dann sind wir wieder endlich, weil wir hatten jetzt immer dieses Problem Nullerjahre, Zehnerjahres, das klingt alles beschissen. Und dann kann man jetzt endlich wieder Zwanzigerjahre sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das überhaupt noch durchsetzen wird. Bei so Neunziger, Achtziger, Siebziger, Sechziger sagt jeder gerne. Da hat man immer ein Lächeln auf dem Mund, wenn man das sagt. Zwanziger klingt jetzt schon nach Babylon Berlin oder so. Ja, ja, genau, klar. Es klingt schon nach Great Gatsby, klingt jetzt schon. Aber setzt sich das dann durch. So auch Nullerjahre, glaube ich, habe ich in meinem Leben nie gesagt.
Also so zwischen 2000 und 2010.
Und ein Zehner sagt man auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dieser Trend bei 20er Jahren wieder anfängt oder ob das jetzt einfach sich erledigt hat.
Ja, aber dann freut mich schon auf die 30er.
Ja, die wilden 30er.
Naja, aber das kannst du ja nicht sagen.
Die sind ja besetzt.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das ist ja dann immer 100 Jahre her.
Du redest ja auch nicht von den 18er-30ern, wenn du sagst 30er, die hatten ja damals auch das Problem wahrscheinlich. Rom, Caesar hat schon gesagt, wie, was meint ihr, 20er? Nach dem germanischen Kalender?
Die werden wahrscheinlich die 50er miterleben werden.
Die 50er Jahre, die wilden 50er.
Ich nicht, weil ich da vorgestorben bin. War da eigentlich alle wild eigentlich?
Die wilden 60er, die wilden 70er.
Aber wie werden die 2050er miterleben?
Alter Vater, das kann man sich ja gar nicht vorstellen.
Wie werden die 2050er miterleben. Alter Vater, das kann man sich ja gar nicht vorstellen. Wir werden die 2050er erleben. 50er Jahre. Die 50er Jahre werden wir erleben noch. Kann gut sein, kann gut sein. Ich glaube, dass wir eh alle über 100 werden. Ich glaube, alle, die diesen Podcast hören, werden über 100 Jahre alt. Alle, die Podcast hören und keinen Flugschein machen, werden über 100 Jahre alt. Ja, die Luft ist so gut, das Wasser ist so sauber, die Kekse sind so ...
Wetter ist toll. Weil die Podcasts hören und keinen Flugschein machen werden. Die Luft ist so gut, das Wasser ist so sauber, die Kekse sind so gut eingepackt, da kommt kein Bakterium rein. Wenn du eine Flasche Sprite aufmachst, das ist so gut versiegelt, da ist nichts drin. Du kannst gar nicht sterben, weil das ist alles sauber. Du setzt dich irgendwo hin und das ist sauber. Du duschst dich jeden Tag mit Shampoo, das ist alles sauber. Da kann nichts passieren. Verstehst du, wie ich meine? Ich glaube auch. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, wie da irgendwas passieren sollte. Das Gute ist, an den Silvesterbrillen, diese typischen Jahresbrillen, kann man dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal wieder durchgucken. Ja, endlich. Dann kann man ja durchgucken. Endlich, dann hast du halt die zwei auf der Nase. 2020, da sind zwei Löcher drin. Perfekt. Das war die letzten Jahre ein Riesenproblem. Das war ein Riesenproblem. Ich war immer auf einem Auge blind. 2017, holy shit, nichts. 2016, Loch zu klein, von 06. Oder man geht halt heute schon direkt mit 2021 und denkt sich, wie, 20? Scheiße! Und dann rennt man schnell raus. Und den Gag macht man alle zehn Minuten, bis alle sagen, wer ist er eigentlich? Wer ist er? Der ist ja gar nicht eingeladen. Und dann du, ja, aber ich wollte noch was Besonderes machen an Silvester. Einen riesigen Beuler auf dem Kopf, weinend, komplett so rotz und wasser weinend.
Warum kann man sich die Vester nicht verkleiden?
Themenpartys, immer Themenpartys gibt es, gibt es Harry Potter Themenparty. Nur Harry Potter, das ist der eine. Ja, es gibt auch dieses Hobbitfest, du kannst auch den Bilbo-Beutling-Geburtstag, also du kommst zum Bilbo-Beutling-Geburtstag, kannst du machen, frohen Bilbo-Beutling-Geburtstag gibt es immer. Und da kannst du dann die Feuerwerk auch machen, es passt ja, weil das ist ja so eine Art Aunland-Silvester mit dem Feuerwerk. Du kannst den Bilbo-Beuteligen-Geburtstag Silvesterfeier machen? Ja. Wo kann man sich da Informationen sammeln? Nein, das ist natürlich geschlossene Gesellschaft, die Bilbo-Beuteligen-Geburtstag.de kannst du machen. Nee, das ist eine geschlossene Gesellschaft, die Gästeliste ist schon voll. Die Gästeliste ist schon voll. Gandalf, die Beutlins, Smaug, Smaug, darf auch kommen, Familie Smaug, Saruman, eingeladen, kommt aber nicht. Kommt aber natürlich nicht. Aber hat abgesagt, nett, eine Karte. Wahrscheinlich schon. Ja, sowas finde ich ganz gut, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Aber ich schaue immer Herr der Ringe zu Weihnachten. Ah, ich auch. Das kommt jetzt meine Tradition und es gibt mittlerweile auch auf Amazon Prime die Extended Edition. Für alle, die die Extended Edition nicht kennen, schaut die euch auf jeden Fall an. Ich kenne viele Leute, die sagen, oh, ich schaue mir jedes Jahr Herr der Ringe an und dann frage ich, ah ja, cool, die Szene mit den Bäumen, oder? Wie Bäume? Ja, Extended Edition. Schaut die Extendedended Edition an. Ja, aber die Szene mit den Bäumen ja auch in der ganzen Edition. Ja, aber nicht, dass sie in Helms Clump dann noch die Bäume auftauchen. Was? Ja! Das ist nicht in der Extended Edition? Ne, ich kenne das, ich kenne die Szene sehr gut. Ja, nee, das ist nicht in der normalen Edition. Was? Ja, und alle so, hä, wie und dann ist es ja Bäume in Helms Clump. Ja, es hört einfach auf. Wie, es hört einfach auf? Ja, Gandalf taucht auf und dann hat die Schlacht gewonnen. Never. Doch, das ist die normale Version. Ach, Helmsklamm. Ja, Helmsklamm, nicht Isengard. Da sind die auf jeden Fall. Helmsklamm, natürlich sind die in Isengard, das ist ja Plattpunkt, aber die Bäume sind auch in Helmsklamm. Nee, die sind im Wald. Ja, aber die sind bei Helmsklamm, die sind nach Helmsklamm gelaufen. Ah ja. So, schaut euch die Extended Edition an, verdammt nochmal. Aber dann ist es doch gar nicht mehr so spannend, dass sie dann in Isengard auftauchen. Oder es ist der gleiche Film. Der gleiche Film. Der gleiche Film, ne? Ja, ich muss die nochmal gucken. Es ist auch so bei mir, ich gucke dann Filme jedes Jahr wirklich. Und ich bin mir auch sehr, dass ich, bei zwei Filmen weiß ich nicht, ob ich die Ex-Eventer-Version geguckt habe. Aber sonst eigentlich schon immer. Und ich weiss immer nicht viel. Ich vergesse alles. Ich vergesse so viel. Ja, aber das ist ja auch schön, das ist ja auch gut. Ich glaube, das Gehirn macht irgendwann auch aus, wenn man irgendwas zu oft mitbekommt, dann sagt man, das ist ungefährlich. Wenn etwas einmal im Jahr passiert, dann ist es ungefährlich und dann merkt sich das Gehirn das nicht mehr, weil es sich denkt, ich bin bis jetzt noch nie gestorben und es ist jedes Jahr passiert. Passt schon, das kann so rein aus. Du bist da bei Rocket Beans und machst so einen Trouble Pursuit und da denkt das Gehirn dann, oh, ist doch gefährlich.
Ah, da ist er doch.
Ja, gut.
Wann willst du rein?
Es ist dein Büro. Es ist schon dein Büro. Gibst du uns noch 20 Minuten? 10 Minuten? Ja, das ist total geil. Ja, danke. Oh, ja. Wir müssen uns hier immer irgendwie einkaufen in fremde Büros und werden immer rausgescheucht. Und mit Einkaufen meint er einfach reinsetzen. Ja, aber es stimmt schon, ich habe auch mit Leuten geredet, dann haben wir auch über Helmsklamm diskutiert. Und da gibt es ja diesen Wettbewerb zwischen Gimli und Legolas, wer mehr Uruk-Kai töten kann und die meisten Leute wissen gar nicht, wie das ausgeht. Ja! Schaut die Extended Edition, da seht ihr, wie dieser Wettkampf ausgeht, wer gewinnt? Immer diese Leute, die dann sagen, ich bin ein riesen Hedder-Ringe-Fan und dann gucken sie nicht die die fucking Extended. Die meisten wissen ja auch gar nicht, dass Dumbledore am Ende von Rückkehr des Königs dafür sorgt, dass die Armee da noch reinkommt und Mordor besiegt. Und im ersten Teil, als Gandalf mit seiner Pfeife so Rauchgestalten macht, da macht er Mickey Maus. Und Bilbo fragt, was ist das? Und er sagt, Bilbo sagt, haben wir überhaupt die Rechte dran? Ja. Und Ganderer sagt, oh. Die Szene geht ewig lang mit diesen Rauchzeichen. Er zaugt immer und dann sagt er irgendwie so ein Obszönes und dann Zwinker da und Stöß und Bilbo so beschämt, wischt es so aus seinem Buch wieder. Es geht anderthalb Stunden. Es geht ewig lang und alle sind dabei und dann Gran Turismo 4 und man denkt sich, war das, gab es da einen Werbediener oder was? Es ist ganz, ganz merkwürdig. Und das schätzteste Figur aus allen herterigen Teilen ist übrigens der Mund Sarumans. Ja, herrlich. Herrlich. Sieht man von dem mehr in der Extended-Version? Der ist nur in der Extended-Edition. Er ist nur in der Extended-Version. Den Mund von Saruman gibt es in der normalen Version nicht.
Das ist eine absurde Figur, die so viel Spaß macht. Aber es ist schon ein bisschen problematisch, wenn dein Bösewicht ein riesiges, feuriges Auge ist und man denkt sich, unser Bösewicht hat keinen Dialog? Ne, unser Bösewicht kann nicht sprechen und kann seinen Willen nicht ausdrücken. Ach, der Mund Saurons, sehr klar. Ja, und dann gibt es den Mund Saurons, wo man sich überlegt, wie könnte der aussehen? Der hat einen riesen Mund. Riesen Mund. Er hat keine Augen, weil an Augen mangelt ihm ja nicht. Ja, das ist richtig. Das wäre Verschwendung. Ja, wenn dieser Mensch auch noch Augen hätte. Verschwendung. Weil es ist ja ein Mensch, nehme ich mal an. Das ist ja kein Ork. Das ist ja ein Mund. Ja, aber so. Und dann kommt der, und ich weiß noch, und vor allem schaut die Extended Making-of Edition, das ist großartig, weil die haben überlegt, ja, wie könnte der Mund von sauren aussehen. Weil das ist immer das Problem, so im Buch stellt sich jeder was anderes vor, man hat so irgendein Bild. Aber im Film musst du da halt ganz viele kleine Fragen beantworten. Hat der Fingernägel? Wie sieht, was hat der eine Hose an? So, das sind alles so diese Kleidfragen, die man beantworten muss. Und dann haben die sich überlegt, sie wollten den Mund senkrecht machen.
Wie das Auge.
Kommt darauf an, wie du jetzt das Auge siehst, weil Saurons Auge ist ja so ein bisschen Katzenaugenmässig mit der Schlitzpupille.
Aber wenn du ein Lied denkst, aber halt generell, der normale Mund ist horizontal und der wäre vertikal, so aufrecht, die irgendwo hin zu der Ecke rumläuft, das Ohrläppchen sauber, die Nase sauber, hau ab jetzt, Mord, oh am Mord, nee, das kannst du nicht machen, ach ja, stimmt, das muss der Mund machen. Es ist einfach so ein riesiger Mr. Potato Head, ist einfach diese Sauron-Figur. Hinten und vorne stimmt das nicht zusammen. Aber die haben sich letztendlich dagegen entschieden, diesen vertikalen Mund zu machen, weil es komplett bescheuert aussieht. Weil die Zähne sind ja trotzdem noch auf einer Seite. Und es ist einfach so... Weil die dann die Zähne auf einer Seite hat oder was? Seitlich? Ja, ich verstehe schon, was du meinst. Das ist schon problematisch. Man ist zwar für viele Fragen konfrontiert, das ist so richtig. Ich finde es auch geil bei den Extended-Versionen, die Making-of sind total spannend, sind auch ewig lang. Und da sieht man halt genau, wie viele Möglichkeiten es gibt, so eine Welt zu erzählen. Und dann haben die so geile Leute besorgt, die damals so Konzeptzeichnungen gemacht haben, auch für die Bücher und so. Die hat Peter Jackson ja auch alle angerufen und eingeladen. Und dann ist total cool, wie er dann immer auf den Drehpausen, weil die ja im Stücke dreht, in Drehpausen dann in so Räume gebeten wird, wo ganz viele Whiteboards stehen mit Vorschlägen und er da einfach nur steht und drauf zeigt auf die Dinge, die wir später sehen, aber er hätte auch einfach ein Zentimeter da nach links zeigen können jeweils und es wäre ein anderer Film geworden. Und Gollum wäre irgendwie so blau mit so einem Hütchen auf oder so gewesen. Ja, mit so einem Zittilmütziger. Und vor allem die coolste Figur und ich freue mich jedes Mal, wenn ich ihn sehe in diesem Making-of, ist der, keine Ahnung, Name, Name, Name, Bauchbinde und dann Elvish Language Expert. Und ich denke mir, noch nie war ein Mensch so glücklich über einen Anruf wie ein Elvish Language Expert, der hat sein Leben lang Elbisch gelernt und eines Tages bring bring, hallo guten Tag, ja guten Tag, New Line Cinema hier, wir würden einen Herr der Ringe Film drehen, drei Teile, hätten Sie Lust da mitzuarbeiten? Ja, ja, endlich, endlich hat mein Leben einen Sinn. Karen, es hat geklappt, Karen! A lunacy noisthen, was? New Line Cinema, Thoind, Thalha, Hain, Hain, Hain! Thoinderset, Honden, New Line Cinema, Peter Jackson, oder? Wow! Ich meine, wie fucking glücklich muss dieser Mensch sein, der sein Leben der elbischen Sprache findet. Aber stell mir vor, dass diese Nummer, auf der er angerufen wurde, noch bis zum nächsten Tag konnte er die Rechnung bezahlen für diese Tresnetz-Telefonnummer. Ja, genau. Und danach war er abgelaufen, weil er hat keinen Job. Und stell dir den Elbisch-Language-Expert vor, den sie davor angerufen haben, der nicht rangegangen ist, und dann haben sie den anderen genommen. Dann denken sie sich, nein, nein, ich bin nicht. Und die zwei hassen sich natürlich auch, es sind zwei Elbisch-Language-Experts. Ja, waren schon ein paar Grammatikfehler bei Arwen drin, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Wo, das war Gerund? Nee, das ist umgangssprachlich. Wie umgangssprachlich? Das ist zu frontivo. Der Bruchteil-Dialekt ist doch ganz anders. Die haben diesen Blussquam perfekt gar nicht. Ja, aber Arwen ist ja im Ruhrgebiet aufgewachsen. Da kann man mal ein bisschen Herderderer sprechen. Ja, aber Arwen ist ja im Bruchteil aufgewachsen. Ja, aber vor 200 Jahren. Ja, er weiß ja niemand, wie es vor 200 Jahren war. Rufen sich jeden Abend an, um zu reden, um zu streiten. Sie hassen sich, aber sie haben auch sonst niemanden, mit dem sie sprechen können. Ja, man wünscht sich dann irgendwie erst mal an, dass noch irgendwann eine geile Frau auch noch. Ja. Aber niemand lernt diese Sprache. Niemand lernt diese Sprache. Aber der ist auf jeden Fall so fucking happy in diesem Making-of. Weil das sind ja schon alles Nerds auch, die jetzt nicht ihre Freude so ausdrücken, aber man merkt einfach, der freut sich, dass er endlich das machen kann, was er sein Leben lang trainiert hat. Und es ist auch, es ist grossartig. Und da gab es dann auch so Wörterbüche, ne, Elbisch, gab es bestimmt viele Weihnachtsgeschenke in dem Jahr, in dem Herr der Ringe rauskam, viele Elbisch-Wörterbücher, auch ungelesen weggeworfen. Wahrscheinlich. Auf jeden Fall. Und da gibt es auch diese tollen Zeichnungen von, ja, primär so Fans, die ja damals, als die Bücher rauskamen, Zeichnungen ergestellt haben, unter anderem von dem Balrog, der mit Gandalf die bei der Mine von Moria runterfällt und so und das ganz toll schon gezeichnet haben, was Peter Jackson einfach eins zu eins benutzt hat als Image, auch in dem Film. Ganz toll. Auch für solche Leute natürlich toll, einen Anruf zu bekommen, aus ihren blöden Zeichnungen, wo sich die Mutter darüber aufregt, dass sie einen Großteil der Wohnung einnehmen, irgendwann zu Geld machen können. Das ist natürlich cool. Ja, mega gut. Ich habe eh schon Bock. Ich weiß nicht, wann darf man anfangen mit solchen Weihnachtstradition Oh, ich glaube so Ende November. Ende November geht schon. Ab dem 21. November, glaube ich. Ja, aber ich dachte eigentlich so in dieser zwischen Weihnachten und Silvesterphase, wo man nichts zu tun hat, nichts macht, voll gefressen ist den ganzen Tag, da kann man das gut machen. Weil ich will es dann auch nicht verpulgern. Ich habe noch eine zweite Tradition, dass ich mir immer die Oceans-Filme anschaue, auch zu Weihnachten. Oh, die habe ich jetzt schon geschaut. Die habe ich letzte Woche schon geschaut. Ja? Ja, ah geil. Wirklich absurde Filme. Also, weil die sind so originell. Da stimmt alles. Ja. Absurde Kamera, ganz komische Zooms, wo jeder Kameramann, der bei Trost ist, sagen würde, das ist total bad taste. Aber in diesem Film ist es total zum Stilmittel geworden und weiß nicht. Alles so, das ist, wo man sich auch fragt, was war zuerst da? War das Grundkonzept, die Grundvision da oder haben alle die Paten es wieder mal wieder alles richtig gemacht? Ich müsste eigentlich auch mal den das Original sehen, ich glaube, hat da nicht sogar Frank Sinatra mitgespielt? In Ocean's Eleven, es gibt ja irgendwie aus den wilden 60ern. Ein Buch, es basiert ja auf einem Buch. Und dann gibt es noch einen Film und dann, genauso wie Inglourious Basterds, ja auch auf einem Film basiert, den es schon gibt. Es gibt schon einen Film, doch den schreibt man auch anders. Der heißt dann, weil Inglourious Basterds sehr falsch geschrieben. Das weiß ich ja eben nicht, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen. Ich glaube, vielleicht ist das Grundkonzept gleich von irgendwie so zehn Soldaten, die Nazis jagen oder so, aber vielleicht muss man sich auch das mal angucken, ein bisschen Geschichte auch. Man ist so, man hat so einen Widerstand, alte Filme anzuschauen, dass es eigentlich schade ist. Das habe ich nicht, tatsächlich. Echt, ich habe einen riesen Widerstand. Ich würde gerne mal sagen, dieses Wochenende mal alle Hitchcock wegbingen. Aber irgendwie ist der Widerstand einfach da. Obwohl ich rationalisiere, dass es Bullshit ist und ich auch schon viele alte Filme gerne gesehen habe, aber trotzdem schaue ich mir dann lieber noch irgendwie ... Aber übertrete mal die Hemmschwelle, bei Hitchcock glaube ich, ist man so erstaunlich, wie modern die sind. Sei es geschnitten, vom Tempo her auch, wo man immer Angst hat, auch vom Humor her teilweise sehr ähnlich. Also gerade Hitchcock ist natürlich seinerzeit der Voraus. Dem kannst du mal eine Chance geben.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das ist doch nicht schlecht. Wir fangen mal so jetzt in diese Zeitalter, die Jahreszeit der Tradition, können wir jetzt mal wieder anfangen. Gut, dass wir gerade noch gesagt haben, Traditionen sind Bullshit und wir wollen nichts für die 200 Folge machen. Ja, Traditionen sind scheinbar. Nee, Traditionen sind für Vollgioten. Ich halte das Traditionen. Na. Tja, ich habe jetzt am Wochenende kommt die Familie zusammen und alle haben sich überlegt, ein Raclette zu machen, weil es immer, irgendein Monat vor Weihnachten kommt die Familie zusammen bei uns, irgendwie ein Traditionsding und machen halt dieses Bullshit-Familienraclette, wo ich jetzt immer überlegt habe, nein, weil ich habe jetzt einen Schweizer Autorenkollegen, mit dem ich oft über die Schweiz rede und der mir jetzt ein Rezept gegeben hat für Käsefondue, klassisches Schweizer Käsefondue, wo ich jetzt wirklich all in gehe. Also ich habe mir schon so viel gekauft und habe mir von einem Schweizer Koch ein Rezept besorgt. Und ich ballere jetzt am Wochenende, tische ich meiner Familie, das krasseste Käsefondue, was Deutschland je gesehen hat. Da habe ich dann auch Ambitionen, das perfekt zu machen. Da zieht sich mein Perfektivismus gnadenlos auch durch. Da mischt man dann auch verschiedene Käsesorten.
Zwei Käsesorten, Gruyere und Vacherin Foubois-Jas.
Genau, 50-50, das nennt man dann Mati-Mati.
Mati-Mati?
Mati-Mati, das ist Hälfte-Hälfte, glaube ich.
Da kommen dann noch Gewürze rein,
Muskat, Pfeffer,
Maisstärke natürlich, dann
ein bisschen Weisswein, trocknen aber dann lieber. Dann muss man auch ein bisschen Kirschlikör, also Kirschwasser macht man da rein, kann aber, ich überlege aber das so ein bisschen exkluierter zu machen, jeder bekommt so ein Kirschlikör vor sich gestellt und dann kann man das selber reinmixen, wenn man es vielleicht nicht mag unbedingt oder keinen Alkohol trinkt. Das wird ganz grandios gefeiert. Und was in der klassischen Schweizer Küche tunkt man dann da rein? Brot. Nur Brot? Nur Brot, ja. Also da gibt es dann nicht irgendwie Gürtchen. Nein, das Ding ist ja, der Käse steht im Vorgrund. Du zelebrierst ja den Käse. Das ist ja das Tolle daran, das perfide, dass die Deutschen dann meinen, nee, wir machen uns so eine Fleischfondue machen wir uns, weil wir müssen das Fleisch, nein, der Käse wird gewertschätzt, Käse wird gewertschätzt, Brot ist nur ein Beimittel, Beimittel, um die Carbs, das Fett zu binden, aber direkt Löffeln ist ein No-Go. Nee, das klumpt im Magen, deswegen braucht man das Brot. Aber deswegen eigentlich nur Weissbrot, so ein klassisches Baguette oder sowas.
Aber da gehe ich auch gut einkaufen, zum schönen Bäcker, wo ein organisches Baguette mal wieder kommt auf den Tisch. Das wird ganz toll. Das zelebriere ich, ich berichte euch davon und dann vielleicht stelle ich das Rezept auch mal irgendwann online. Es ist aber ein so geil schamloses Gericht einfach so. Wir haben einen riesigen Topf geschmolzenen Käse und essen den einfach auf. Ja, so, das war's. Nicht irgendwie wie eine Pizza, wo du den Käse dann in einem Ofen oder mit Belag und Brot, sondern nee, wir lassen den ganzen Tomatenteil, wir lassen den ganzen Rucola-Teil, das lassen wir alles weg und haben halt hauptsächlich Käse. Ich freue mich da sehr drauf, ich bin sehr gespannt, ihr werdet davon berichten, wie es gelaufen ist. Ihr gibt in Köln lustigerweise einen guten Käseladen, das Käsehaus, wo man wirklich sämtliche Käse bekommt. Und die machen einem das auch schon fertig, also die raspeln dem einen auch schon klein. Ah, das ist geraspelt, wollte ich gerade fragen, und dann, so kann man es dann besser schmelzen, oder was? Eingeschmolzen mit dem Weisswein, Zitronensaft, ja. Ist wie eine Supp eine Suppe eigentlich auch ein bisschen. Eine Käsesuppe. Es ist eine Käsesuppe. Ja, aber ich würde Suppe nicht sagen, weil dafür ist der Anteil an Käse zu groß. Und ist es dann auch so, dass man Käse reintunkt und dann so ganz lange Fäden zieht? Man hat lange Fäden, ja. Und dann, ah, jetzt, ah, dann dreht man es so ein und dann, ah, über Rita drüber, müssen alle über Rita die Fäden ziehen. Irgendwann ist die ganze Wohnung voller Fäden.
Eingesponnen wie so ein Spinnennest einfach, wo einfach alles voller Streifen ist.
Ja, und dann kommt Aragog und isst dich.
Wie heißt die Spinne aus der Ringe?
Die exakt die gleiche Spinne ist?
Hätte man einfach nehmen können.
Ach so.
Aragog isst die von Harry Potter, die große Spinne.
Heißt auch so ähnlich wie Aragorn, da geht alles durcheinander kurz, da ist kurze Glitch in den Franchises. Arbok? Arbok. Ich glaube, du bist jetzt gerade bei Pokémon, aber naja. Finden wir heraus bis nächste Woche. Wie heisst die Herr der Ringesspinne, fuck. schilop heißt sie im Englischen. Schilop? Schilop. Schilop. Einfach Schilop. Schilops, Schilops Lair. Oder einfach so Dave. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo Tolkien auch sagt, Leute, ich habe zwölftausend Namen, ich habe wirklich Mythologien mehr erfunden und so eine scheiss Spinne, die heißt Paul. Ja, Dave. So, fertig. Fertig einfach. Aber ich glaube, es ist vor allem Tolkien ist ja gleichzeitig, glaube ich, einer der faszinierendsten Autoren, aber auch einer der enttäuschendsten, weil alle haben Herr der Ringe gelesen, fanden es geil, haben die Filme gesehen, haben sich dann das Silmarillion geholt und dachten sich, ich steige jetzt richtig tief ein und es ist das fucking langweiligste Buch der Welt. Herr der Ringe ist leider schon sehr langweilig geschrieben, aber Silmarillion ist so, ich weiß nicht, ob du mal die Bibel gelesen hast. Die Bibel fängt ja an mit Paradies, super spannend, geil, gute Gags, super Sachen, interessante Geschichten. Und dann kommt der zweite Teil ewig lang und Jakob zeugte Ismael und Ismael zeugte Valentin und Valentin zeugte Karloan und Karlojan zeugte und das über Seiten hinweg, weil die Autoren natürlich ein riesen Problem hatten, die Zeitabstände irgendwie zu erklären, weil Paradies muss ja super früh gewesen sein und dann kommt Mose und alle wollen zu Moses, aber du musst halt tausende von Jahren überbrücken. Warum kannst du schneiden? Du kannst einfach 12.000 Jahre später. Ja, vor allem die haben alle übermenschlich lang gelebt und Isaac lebte 400 Jahre und Paulonius sechs und denkst dir, warum leben Menschen heute nicht mehr so lange und denkst dir, ja, weil wir uns nicht so viel in den Arm ausdenken. Und genauso ist Silmarillion auch. Nicht einfach super lang. Ja, aber auch bei Tolkien sind sich alle einig, dass die Bücher nicht wirklich, ist ja kein guter Literat. Er war ja irgendwie Englischprofessor, richtig, oder Sprachenprofessor.
Jedenfalls sehr tief, Akademiker, kam halt von so einer Sprachschule und hat deswegen ja auch primär, glaube ich, es gedickt, diese Sprache zu erfinden und diese Welt darum, aber hat keinen besonderen Interesse an Dramaturgie gehabt. Ah, der hätte nochmal so einen Tarantino gebraucht, der da nochmal drüber liest, der da einfach nochmal so spannende Dialoge, irgendwie
richtig knackige, spannende Szenen
irgendwie auf den Punkt und nicht immer dieses
ewige und dann diese Lieder.
Selbst der grösste Herr der Ringe-Fan hat die Lieder
einfach übersprungen, weil er denkt, da passiert
gar nichts, da passiert
überhaupt nichts, einfach weiter.
Aber naja.
Und drei Seiten weiter. Ach herrlich, das ist eine halbe Antenne auslandgeworden. Hast du einen Kamin zuhause eigentlich? Nein, nein. Meine Heizung ist immer noch nicht an, ich habe keine Heizung. Ich brauche einen Kamin, glaube ich, zuhause, um her dringend zu schauen. Weil ich muss immer niesen, wenn die Heizung an ist, deswegen versuche ich die immer möglichst lange auszuhalten und denke mir, wenn mir kalt ist, nehme ich eine kurze warme Dusche. Sehr gut. Und dann ist mir wieder warm. Machen wir so. So, wir müssen den Raum rollen. Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche. Hedringer guckt Ocean's Eleven und wir sehen uns nächste Woche. Habt ihr Weihnachtstraditionen? Wenn ja, ganz viel Spaß damit erstmal. Und hauen rein, wenn ihr weiterhin euch mit Afrika auskennt. wir würden uns weiter über weitere Beiträge freuen. Ja, und uns hat auch aus Togo geschrieben. Wir freuen uns sehr über den Beitrag. Macht gerne einen Beitrag. Djibouti. Ich kann einen Beitrag aus Togo machen. Ja, klar, natürlich. Haut rein, wir freuen uns von euch zu hören. Es gibt manchmal Tickets für Mainz und Socken in so einem Onlineshop. Feiert man in Afrika Weihnachten? Was feiert man da? Wann? Gibt es da Trad? Welche? Wollen wir alles wissen? Haut rein, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, wir sagen tschüss und wir heben ab. Vielen Dank an Erik fürs Intro, haut rein, wir heben ab, tschüss.